when jQuery first came out it made a
bunch of things a lot easier than just
using normal JavaScript
however vanilla JavaScript has caught up
a little bit with jQuery and a lot of
things that jQuery made a lot easier
Manilla javascript can do it just as
easily let's go through some of the new
vanilla JavaScript alternatives to
jQuery methods well here's how you
select an element so here's a jQuery way
of selecting an element and then here's
the vanilla JavaScript way of selecting
an element it's only a few more
characters to do the JavaScript way now
let's see how to remove an element so
that's how you would remove an element
in jQuery and then let's see how you
would remove an element in JavaScript as
you can see it's exactly the same now
let's see how to propel iment let's
change this to prepend now in the
parentheses we have to put what other
element we're going to prepend and then
the vanilla JavaScript way and again is
exactly the same if you want an insert
an element before another element you
can use before and this time I'm just
gonna copy and paste because it's
exactly the same if you want to replace
an element with another element replace
with and again it's exactly the same
with vanilla JavaScript if you want to
find the closest ancestor that matches a
given selector you just use closest and
then you pass in the selector div and
again we're just gonna copy and paste
because this is another thing that's
been implemented in normal JavaScript
now we're gonna go over a few things
that are a little longer than vanilla
JavaScript so jQuery does make them
easier but they're still pretty easy in
JavaScript
the first one is fade in so here's how
you're gonna fade in an element in
jQuery and vanilla JavaScript first
you're going to have to use some CSS so
you're gonna have to put in the initial
CSS here you're gonna put display:none
opacity zero transition 0.8 seconds so
it's not going to be display at the
beginning and now you're just going to
put in this other
code Elam dot styled that display equals
block so you're going to set the display
to block and then you're just gonna do
requestanimationframe and you're gonna
set the opacity to one so it's gonna
start at zero and go up to one and 0.8
seconds and yet for the fade and you
still have to select the item
I didn't mean to delete that another
thing that jQuery has is dot animate so
the dot animate method would look like
this to animate an object so you're just
gonna pass in all the CSS properties you
want to animate and the time 1500
milliseconds now JavaScript now has the
web animations API that makes animation
pretty easy and it gives you a lot more
power than the dot animate method from
jQuery so here's how you're gonna
animate in vanilla JavaScript again it's
not animate and you just passed in the
initial state of the element the CSS and
then the state of the CSS after it's
been animated and then the length of the
animation 1000 milliseconds so another
key selling point of jQuery in the past
has been Ajax jQuery made it a lot
easier to do Ajax instead of using the
XML HTTP request so here's one of the
ways to do Ajax and jQuery so you're
gonna pass in the URL and then if it's
success you're gonna do something with
this data javascript now has the fetch
API with the fetch API it's almost a
simple C you're gonna pass in the URL
and then you're gonna put what's going
to happen with the data now here's the
almost catch to doing things with
vanilla JavaScript some of these things
are still not supported by Internet
Explorer and edge
however I say almost catch because
pretty much everything can be polyfilled
and poly filling may be easier than you
think there's a website called polyfill
I oh if you just put in this one line of
code at the top of your website
everything will be poly filled it will
automatically check which browser the
the user of the website has and only
bring in the code that's needed for that
specific browser so only brings in the
polyfill code that's absolutely
necessary to bring that browser
to date so you may be thinking if
JavaScript has all these things do I
still need to learn jQuery well it's
still good to become familiar with it
because jQuery is still using a lot of
websites so you're probably gonna come
in contact with it eventually you should
just know that for a lot of things you
don't even really need jQuery for this
whole video was based on an article by
Ollie Williams called now more than ever
you might not need jQuery on CSS tricks
com I highly recommend checking out the
original article I have the link in the
description well thanks for watching my
name is beau Carnes don't forget to
subscribe and remember use your code for
good